e aí galera que existe um canal você e
então por que toca tudo bom me tá bom
porque toda a minha casa nova a pai
velho e depois da morte favorecer
mercado nova e domingo passado agora foi
que das criança a adiantar childress
gente criança eu coisa que o golpe eu
adoro criança gente eu amo crianças
ela domina eu adoro porque acordada o
teu do seu bicho tem moneo criança
acordado é uma coisa que não tem seguro
e eu só corro muito apertada gente pior
que na bíblia diz bem aventurada as
crianças porque delas é o reino dos céus
a gente fica imaginando o céu cheio de
criança usando tudo bonito agora não
senhor que a ciência é maravilhosa mas
tu fala de criança como se nunca tivesse
sido criança gente eu já fui criança só
que quando eu era criança minha mãe me
dá o limite se tem uma coisa que meu pai
me ensinar tudo graças a deus por ter
aprendido é o seguinte criança não fala
em contado tá falando criança não passa
no meio contador está conversando
criança temporária da criança e um
adulto morador duro usado estivesse
conversando eu cheguei a falar alguma
coisa pois é mulher do acredita que eles
cinco maiores ele que eu cheguei ela
está bem cheia ó estacionou o carro aí
quando vê vai tá bem chegando nada chega
à dengue e mãe não estava enxergando a
ordem é seguir falar olha mulher tovim
aqui maior e chtou de um só eu mas
sozinho que o pneu do meu carro furou
mas tabém chão tamanho continental do
menino
ae
pois é me mas eu até estava na hora eu
ficava uma calma que meu deus numca
minha tranquilidade agora essa
presenciar o índice sueli é apologia à
severidade a o índice apologia ao
agressor não
não é isso e outra hora só matéria é do
carro não a minha mãe ela me tocava só
com o olhar se não tem assunto que eu to
galera me preparar pra fazer sangue
o ovo um bora brincar de mergulhar na
areia
o
esse é o menino adora brincar de contar
conta uma piada mas vai dar em mim eu
lembro de quando era pequena que que
muitas pessoas não não lembro desse
momento e quando a pessoa para o desafio
que é o pico que era um pipo gente o
pico é você bota na boca a passar o
tempo enquanto você não tamanho da
criança é toda hora tentaram feitou na
hora o ingresso nem sabia se passar o
dia todo e chupetinha gente tem feito
que aguente ainda só passar seis anos
pendurada no peito quando terminasse de
pagar seu peito bitupitá aparece no
futuro vai criar o pipoca por toma fica
aí finge tamanho todo mundo quase todo
mundo já baixou um pouco e eu lembro do
dia que eu parei e além do dia que eu
parei de usar a filha é o está guardada
na minha memória gente estava na rede
balançando eu deitar na rede só quem é
mãe na casa com rooney que terá foco
internet rádio a mãe placa eu fiquei
olhando chama admirar que está fazendo
uma limpa na casa uma olhada que eu dei
um puxão gente meu pico cair do jeito
que está passando por essa feijoada deu
a volta e puxou pips
tão bonito era mais íntimo rock em cima
ele era um tipo lindo também vindo
daquele dia nunca mais enxuto campo e
nunca mais deixei que outro pintado no
lugar do meu pi é o meu dia que eu vejo
também o elenco era criança eu fiz uma
coisa que nunca mais faço na minha vida
eu e meu irmão foi um banho no banheiro
néis que você está pensando agora
começam a brigar brigar brigamos mãe de
roberta acontecendo aqui
angelita batendo em quem está batendo
perto os dois vão apanhar pegou sintasa
humala padrinho da honra para mim ela
saiu de dentro do boi gente não estava
fechando a porta do banheiro e assim nem
doeu pra quê meu deus gente na mesma
hora eu comecei a sentir um cheiro
diferente do que cheiro de morte ela era
minha mãe deu mesmo ao eu costumo dizer
que tem três coisas que marcaram a minha
vida e de virgindade chega a 1 milhão de
inscritos o youtube essa 5 lapada da
minha mãe o que o está marcado às suas
costas a marcar na minha alma em
espírito e outra vez que aconteceu uma
coisa que a gente meu deus do céu sabe
aquela frase diga com quem tu andas que
eu te digo quem com ferro fere pois essa
é a minha vida meu irmão um dia 2
pagador tony que tinha gente no banheiro
é ocupado bichim meu que eu faço eu vou
fazer meu deus o que eu vou eu vou medir
um chá embora aqui no cargo na garagem
desgraçado meu pai foi tirar o kaká
evitou lei de bosta fala meu deus que já
foi pago aqui nessa galera quem é foi e
nem fui eu quem foi ou não nessa zona
possam sair nenhum culpa e vai falhar
pareceu não só que meu pai fez potosí
quatro filhos fileira borges quem fosse
não vai apanhar tudo de furto foi não 8
e não itu foi todo ano foi eu não estou
não foi ou não foi nenhum foi um dos
quatro eu quero saber se não aparecer
agora quem foi feita que vai apoiar
todos os quatro eu com medo de apanhar
nem quem foi comer de apanhar a quem foi
feita aqui tá botando medo de apanhar
vou falar só mais uma vez quem foi que
fez aqui foi o pai eu disse foi eu
passava
todo mundo mas se não for pior não o
pior foi que o meu irmão que fez
explicou é k ganha nem cagão desgraça
carro na garagem um livro a cara dele
ainda fica mandando na minha casa eu
quero que você comente aqui em baixo
alguma história engraçada da sua
infância eu quero saber qualquer coisa
engraçada que aconteceu na sua infância
pode comentar com baixo volume é claro
se você tiver gostar do vídeo você clica
em gostei e clicando gostei e me ajuda
demais mais gente vai ver além de ficar
alegre por ter muitos gostei de ouvir e
que quem escrevesse a primeira vez está
assistindo o vídeo eu tenho vários
vídeos quase 190 veículos e assistir
está no facebook agora que você faz e
clique em curtir e você mata um amigo se
nos comentários redes sociais e tem a
descrição do vídeo muito obrigado você
assistir esse vídeo até aqui é nós falou